would you rather wear high heels or a  belly shirt  this is interesting because we've done  both on good mother good morning  we had a high heel challenge and then we  also wrote a song  about discovering our belly buttons and  then like  revealing them to the world i don't know  uh you just wear high heels and you do  it was actually the high heel  lumberjack challenge yeah uh so well we  did things lumberjacks would do  um but we were wearing high heels like  single lumberjack diddy  and dance around or um the heels are  tough man  the mid they are really really tough  mid-drift is great  yeah yeah i mean yeah we're actually  trying to bring the male midriff back  see you guys are good though yeah  [Laughter]